انتهى كاس العالم في قطر بكل لحظاته
السعيده والحزينه في الملاعب فقط لكن لم
ينتهي حضور في وسائل التواصل فبعد ما حقق
المنتخب الارجنتيني حلم قائده اللاعب
ليونيل ميسي بفوزه على فرنسا بضربات
الترجيح وبعد ما تعادل كان سيد الموقف
بالوقتين الاصلي او التعادل كان سيد
الموقف بالوقتين الاصلي والاضافي تداولت
صفحات وحسابات على مواقع التواصل بلغات
مختلفه حول العالم منشورات بتقول انه
المصري في المركز الارجنتيني راح يصدر
عمله رسميه عليها صوره ميسي منشورات كثيره
الحقيقه صدرت المشهد وجابت مئات المشاركات
وعشرات الاف التفاعلات على صوره او صوره
لورقه نقديه من فئه الفايزو عليها رسم
لميسي وانه المصري في المركزي فيه مونس
ايروس افضل هذه العمله تقريبا لميسي لانه
كما كان من تكرار اللي عمله مارادونا
لكن يا جماعه هل بالفعل المصرف المركزي
الارجنتيني اصدر عمله بتحمل صوره ميسي
بصراحه لا لانه بعد البحث والتدقيق بحقيقه
هذه المنشورات تبين انه الارجنتين ما
اصدرت عمله عليها صوره ميسي وما في اي اثر
لهذا الخبر من اي مصدر موثوق والموضوع ما
خلص لهون المتحدث باسم المصري في المركزي
فرناندو الونسو
ايضا هو بذات نفسه صرح وقال انه ما في اي
مشروع لاصدار عمله عليها صوره ميسي